who do I think I'm gonna get Dumbo not a
princess
I think Dumbo could be a princess this
BuzzFeed quiz is gonna tell me which
Disney princess I am you say it's as
simple as that but you don't know me
ha ha ha it's never that simple well I
hope I get bail cuz I think she's pretty
cool what are my choices here I'm
thinking
Rapunzel maybe I would like to be Nala
let's see what happens would you rather
have the most beautiful singing voice
but you can't make money off of it be a
famous pop star but everyone hates you
I'll go with the first one well I guess
the second one is more like my character
as Gaston and I'm sort of in his head
space right now so I'm gonna be a famous
pop star but everybody hates you would
you rather spend 20 years in jails but
me Ridgid famous will never be rich and
famous but have your freedom
obviously I'll take my freedom buzzfeed
I'm gonna think as Luke in this answer
and say I'd rather be never rich or
famous but have my freedom would you
rather be the best athlete in the world
or be the smartest person in the world
hmm I'll let my body speak for itself on
this one oh I can't skip because I can't
choose smart if you're smart you're
smart if you're an athlete your body is
gonna deteriorate any animal you want as
a domesticated pet any kind of car and
no pet of course I want a cheetah I've
always wanted like a little capuchin
monkey animal I'd have an elephant as a
pet
I don't know cuz not all animals are
meant to be domesticated that's kind of
not fair that I can tell that the car
are clothes is the superficial answer
right I'm gonna go for any animal you
want because then you could always set
it free live in an incredible mansion
but have to stay home always sounds
rubbish travel anywhere in the world but
live in a tiny apartment that's
basically my life
I love luxury and living and luxury but
I think I love travel a little bit more
so I'll take the apartment and I'll hear
my wife complain about it later kick
anyone the house with awesome
superpowers heal any illness or injury
saving any life you want to obviously
that one I'm gonna take the pacifist
approach here if only because I'm
promoting a Disney film these are hard
would you rather know the answer to any
question on any test
always have the perfect comeback to use
on your enemies I'm already pretty good
with comebacks so I'm gonna go with know
the answer to any question on any test
let's go perfect comeback yes it's
terrible but yes like having enemies I
would rather have the answer to any
question Oh ladies and gentlemen look at
this
we call that serendipitous I'm Belle I'm
del I built I caught Ariel is that good
Oh what this is interesting Elsa I got
jasmine everybody knows you for your
beauty but you're more than just a
pretty face you have an adventurous
spirit and a strong will to do I agree
with it I have two right and that the
lore of BuzzFeed
I feel pretty chopped a whole new world
is one of my favorite Disney songs she's
a redhead
I love redheads Thank You BuzzFeed for
bringing out my inner belt I think Josh
GAD who's the voice of Olaf would be
very happy that I got Elsa look at it go
let it go yeah sound like